. All right, we are taking calls via discord
at David Pakman dotcom slash discord.
And we are doing this a little
bit earlier this week because
we are going to be off at the end
of the week due to Thanksgiving.
Let's go next to Amanda, Amanda, who's holding
on to talk to me. What's going on, Amanda?
Amanda, you're on the air. What's going on?
I can hear you, Amanda, what's going on?
Oh, oh, hello.
OK, perfect. So I have a question and I wanted
to know what you think about the lawsuits that
are coming to Trump over the next couple of
months or years once after he leaves office.
I think that the most likely way this will
go is that Trump's businesses are going to be
investigated. And this could mean anything from
money laundering to tax evasion to everything
in between. I think it's quite plausible
that Trump's businesses will have to pay
some fines. We've already seen, you know, Trump
University was disbanded and had to pay a fine.
Trump's charity had to dissolve because of
its using the money as a personal slush fund.
And I think that we will see that. I even
think it's conceivable that there might be
associates of the Trump organization, the business
that could face criminal charges. I don't
know that anybody's going to do any time,
but basically I think that that's as far as it's
going to go. Amanda, that's my sense right now.
OK, and Amanda is gone, Amanda. Amanda left,
and that is it from Amanda, that's too bad.